you didn't mention living a sober life
but you sober sober I've been sober
sober for the past six months
that's Miley Cyrus reviewing her sober
status on varieties big ticket podcast
[Music]
the 27 year old singer tells host marc
malkin that her really important
decision to embrace sobriety began when
she underwent vocal cord surgery last
November it was really funny my doctor
looked at my vocal cords and he said no
one Shai ever has to get this surgery
this is from overuse of the vocal cords
so it's no surprise that I would have
this it's basically I guess probably
from you know I've been touring since I
was 12 years old and again it's not even
the toy and that's the harder part it's
you know you end up staying up late and
things like that and obviously I just
talked Miley's surgery might have been a
necessity but she says it turned out to
be the biggest blessing here's why I did
a lot of family history which again like
has a lot of kind of addiction and you
know kind of mental health challenges
and so just going through that and
saying what why am I the way that I am
and so now I have a better by
understanding the past we understand the
present in the future much more clearly
so I think therapy isn't great the right
minded star says she's determined to
stay the course but she's very real
about the fact that living a sober
lifestyle definitely comes with its
challenges being young you know there's
that stigma like you're no fun and it's
like honey I'm not you can call me a lot
of things but I know that I'm fun so I
know that I'm fun and the thing that I
love about it is waking up 100% 100% of
the time because there are a lot of
challenges again that you wake up and
when there when when we're being asked
to be this active and is on and this
focus and we're gonna be making these
big changes we want to see I don't want
to wake up feeling groggy I want to wake
up feeling ready
and speaking of sobriety Justin Bieber
is another young celeb who's faced
similar struggles Cyrus also discussed
their friendship and we
called a piece of advice she gave him
back in the day I said just try to
remember everything like try to kind of
press record in your brain and remember
everything because there were so many
moments of my life when my mom will be
like do you remember when you got to
perform for the Queen and I'm like no
like I was there was so much going on I
think so much to take in is such a young
person um I didn't remember to like take
everything in Cyrus and Bieber are set
to join forces for what is sure to be a
memorable experience later this month
when they perform along with Shakira
Coldplay Jennifer Hudson and more as
part of NBC's special global goal unite
for our future the concert hosted by
doing the rock Johnson the telecast
which airs Saturday June 27th will
highlight the disproportionate impact
kovat 19 has had on marginalized
communities
[Music]